dans l'actualité ce soir le coup d'envoi
dans toute la france de la vaccination
contre la grippe a comme prévu elle n'a
pas vraiment fait recette on ne s'est
pas bousculé dans les centres malgré
l'exemple très médiatisée de roselyne
bachelot petit règlement de comptes
entre anciens amis charles pasqua accuse
jacques chirac
ils étaient informés des ventes d'armes
à l'angola dit il c'est dans cette
affaire que l'ancien ministre a été
condamné à un an de prison ferme
un témoignage inédit dans ce journal sur
le convoyeur aux 11 millions d'euros
celui de son collègue qui était à ses
côtés dans le fourgon avant le vol pour
lui toni musulin est une énigme
doit-on interdire et télévision aux plus
jeunes enfants ou en limiter l'accès
alors que des chaînes ont été lancés
pour les moins de 3 ans le csa diffuse
une campagne de sensibilisation à
destination des parents et un livre 1
relance les interrogations
la sécheresse s'étend dans l'hémisphère
sud comme l'afrique l'amérique latine
est touchée en australie la canicule et
les incendies sont déjà là on fera le
point sur une expérience agricole en
cours dans le désert du néguev en israël
enfin la vogue des cosmétiques bio ils
représentent une part croissante du
marché
mais faut-il croire à leurs effets et
peut-on être sûr de ce qu'on achète
c'est le dossier de cette édition
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous 1000 centres
ouverts dans toute la france 10 par
département en moyenne c'est parti donc
pour la campagne de vaccination contre
la grippe a le point sur la procédure et
sur la fréquentation perrine bonnet
zidène berkous avec nos bureaux en
région craquer comme des vedettes les
premiers candidats au vaccin
d'autant qu'ils n'étaient pas très
nombreux une centaine dans ce grand
gymnase parisien l'un des 1060 centres
de vaccination ouverts depuis ce matin
même constat avant vous cette mère de
famille était seul à l'ouverture dans ce
centre de l'île avec seulement une
dizaine de vaccination dans la journée
sur eux
oui si à marseille les sept agents et
infirmières se sentais un peu seul ce
matin la population est pas encore
suffisamment motivés ils ont imprégné
des risques qu'elles encourent
ce soir pas d'estimation sur le nombre
de personnes vaccinées
très souvent des malades chroniques mais
pas seulement
je suis d'ailleurs d'un garderie cd en
train que je vais dans que je suis venu
pour le faire vacciner parce que il ya
eu déjà une épidémie dans les songes
travail parce que j'ai été agressé parce
que j'ai du coin tout de défense
immunitaire très bas pour être
tranquille pas être malade protéger des
gens protéger la famille tous ont suivi
le même parcours estimé à 15 minutes
d'abord l'accueil puis ce document à
remplir avec neuf questions du genre
avez vous une réaction grave lors d'une
vaccination fait l'objet d'une contre
indication à une vaccination des
informations très utiles pour le médecin
qui en entretien individuel décide ou
non de prescrire le vaccin si c'est oui
direction la piqûre
et enfin il se retrouve sur le post
finale qui est le poste de traçabilité
dans lequel en fait on va mettre
on va prendre les références du vaccin
afin d'assurer la sécurité sanitaire qui
est nécessaire dans ce cas là ce qui
permet en cas d'effets secondaires
importants de retrouver le lot de
vaccins qui poserait problème
voilà ce que prévoit le dispositif mais
il ya les imprévus le médecin de ce
monsieur lui a conseillé un vaccin non
adjuvanté si on nous posait cette
question parce qu'on n'arrive pas encore
disponibles
la pitié autre souci pour ce père de
famille qui n'a pas reçu le bon pour ses
deux petites filles asthmatiques
la préfecture l'a orienté directement
vers le centre de vaccination il faut
aller dans le cadre à la caisse
d'assurance maladie la plus proche du
domicile les caisses d'assurance maladie
pour fermer le jeu il devra revenir la
machine à éditer les bons n'est pas
encore arrivé alors y at il plus de
monde ce soir dans les centres encore
ouverts bonsoir stéphanie la fuente vous
êtes en direct à haguenau en alsace
qu'elle est l'affluence
alors ici il ya eu un peu plus de monde
que dans les autres sentent précédemment
vu dans le reportage de perrine bonne et
nous allons voir cela avec le directeur
de centre ici ce sont soixante quinze
mille personnes qui pourraient venir
dans ce centre monsieur bell bonsoir
alors combien de personnes sont venues
qui sont allés êtes-vous satisfait
absolument aujourd'hui nous avons eu 86
personnes des enfants des parents des
nourrices des médecins et c'est très
très satisfaisant pour la première
journée et donc monsieur bell vient de
nous le dire des médecins notamment et
il y en a encore un ici ce soir parmi
les derniers à venir c'est monsieur jung
qui est venu se faire vacciner monsieur
young bonsoir oui bonsoir
alors dites nous pourquoi vous faites
vacciner en fait en tant que médecin
généraliste
je ne peux concevoir dont nous pas me
vacciner si votre à la disposition des
patients
par ailleurs je l'invite tout les gens
vraiment à se faire vacciner
et donc comme monsieur young vient de
nous le dire une tout le monde pour
encore venir le centre rouvrira ses
portes demain matin à 9h30 les personnes
prioritaires bien sûr sont prioritaires
mais dans la mesure où il ya
suffisamment de vaccins
tout le monde peut venir même si vous
n'avez pas de bon ici en tout cas on
vous vaccinera offs
et la piqûre et fait merci stéphanie la
fuente ça n'a pas l'air trop douloureux
voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire ce soir
sur le sujet rappelons qu'au canada ou
en suède le public c'est au contraire
massivement présentes et pour se faire
vacciner
un dernier mot et c'est peut-être une
information importante on l'a appris il
ya quelques minutes un cas probable de
syndrome de guillain barré vient d'être
signalée par le ministère de la santé il
pourrait être lié à la vaccination
précisément contre la grippe a il s'agit
vous le savez d'une maladie rare du
système nerveux mais elle n'est pas
forcément grave en l'occurrence il
s'agit semble-t-il d'une forme modérée
qui a évolué favorablement c'est ce que
précise les services de roselyne
bachelot nous y revenons évidemment plus
en détails d'ici à la fin de ce journal
l'actualité judiciaire avec l'offensive
de charles pasqua le show passe quoi
pourrait-on dire dans l'ancien ministre
a fait le spectacle
il avait promis des révélations après sa
condamnation dans la sphère des ventes
d'armes à l'angola et il a effectivement
mis en cause directement aujourd'hui
jacques chirac et dominique de villepin
mais peut-on vraiment parler d'éléments
nouveaux reportages dominique verdeilhan
hervé pozzo une folie médiatique que
charles pasqua n'a jamais connu au cours
de sa carrière politique lui lors de ses
deux procès je vais rafraîchir la
mémoire de jacques chirac et de
dominique de villepin avait il promis
condamné pour avoir touché 230000 euros
en échange d'une intervention dans le
dossier des ventes d'armes à l'angola
entre 93 et 98
charles pasqua ne décolère pas tout les
plus hautes autorités du pays ont été
informés claironne-t-il mais ces
attaques visent d'abord jacques chirac
au japon dame celle que dans toute cette
affaire depuis qu'elle a éclaté
le président de la république l'ancien
président de la république jacques
chirac n'ait jamais assumer ses
responsabilités et je l'accuse de ne pas
avoir assumé ses responsabilités il en
est de même d'ailleurs pour eux
dominique de villepin tous deux ont
manqué à leurs devoirs
pas de révélations mais une défense qui
s'appuie sur des documents déjà aux
mains des juges
charles pasqua se défend de régler des
comptes trois jeunes charge personne je
dis la vérité
dans un communiqué ce soir jacques
chirac rappelle qu'il est favorable à la
levée du secret défense
d'autres dossiers attendent charles
pasqua en avril il sera jugé par la cour
de justice de la république
on en vient maintenant à ce témoignage
dans la sphère toni musulin du nom de ce
convoyeur partie avec 11 millions
d'euros dont 9 ont déjà été retrouvés
depuis plusieurs jours on s'interroge
sur sa double vie et bien ce soir pour
la première fois l'un des deux hommes
qui l'accompagnaient ce jour là dans le
fourgon blindé a accepté de s'exprimer à
lyon benoît gadret thierry simonet il a
les yeux rougis par la fatigue
difficile de trouver le sommeil après un
tel événement philippe ferrero étaient
dans le fourgon blindé lors d'une halte
il est descendu avec son collègue à leur
retour tony musulin avait disparu avec
le camion
on pense à plein de choses qu'on gère
après on dirait qu est ce qu est ce qui
n'a pas été braqué ce qui va pas on n'a
pas forcer à partir
il ya plein de choses qui tourne dans
notre tête sur le coup vous n'avez pas
compris qu'il était parti de lui mais on
n'a pas compris on n'a pas compris la
part de notre collègue on pouvait pas
s'imaginer ça on personne ne puisse
jamais imaginer saint julien non on n'a
pas imaginé à maman qui est les plus
chers se chauffe
est ce qu'il y avait des signes dans son
comportement dans les jours qui ont
précédé qui montraient une certaine
fébrilité
il était fatigué il était fatigué il est
un vrai je le trouvais fatim à la banque
de france c'est toni musulin le
chauffeur qui contrairement à la
procédure s'est occupé du chargement des
billets vous avez su que vous chargez
autant d'argent
non non parce que celui qui avait
qualifié les papiers donc on a pas
non aucun moment on n'a pas on n'a pas
fait attention on gère on avait une
confiance
j'ai confiance en lui voit comment le
convoyeur s'est il mué en voleur pour
philippe ferrero ce serait une sorte de
pied-de-nez d'un homme en mal de
reconnaissance en conflit latent avec
son employeur il a voulu peut-être lancé
un appel jeudi là peut-être voulu lancer
un appel
c'est à dire je sais pas dire regardez
vous nous prenez enfin je veux dire on
n'est pas payé à une juste valeur
peut-être et puis voyez ce que je suis
capable de faire
si vous ne respectez pas regarder ce qui
se passe au jour d'aujourd'hui
philippe ferrero est aujourd'hui mis à
pied le motif est la sanction lui seront
notifiées dans une semaine par son
employeur ce qu'il a fait c'est parce qu
diable mais non je n'en veux pas non
c'est un collègue de travail je vais pas
le dénigrer et ingénieurs maintenant il
nous laisse avec fred interrogations
quoi dans leur fourgon les deux
convoyeurs faisaient équipe depuis
plusieurs mois mais toni musulin était
semble-t-il très discret quant à sa vie
privée
en bref à propos de délinquance le
ministre de l'intérieur brice hortefeux
a présenté aujourd'hui les derniers
chiffres du mois d'octobre et ils
évoquent une rupture après la hausse de
ces derniers mois puisque la baisse est
de 6 % par rapport au même mois de l'an
passé
la gauche ironise en indiquant qu'une
hirondelle ne fait pas le printemps et
en dénonçant je cite une politique
stérile fondée sur la course aux
chiffres
alors on en a parlé ces derniers temps
dans les catégories en augmentation ces
derniers mois il y a les cambriolages
parmi les régions les plus touchées
l'arrière pays cannois est bien là bas
une expérience est en cours celle des
voisins vigilants ils ont décidé de
former des chaînes d'alert enquête
karine comazzi nicolas aubert même quand
elle fait un saut chez sa voisine à 50
mètres de chez elle
madame heureux 18 ferme sa porte à clé
on sait jamais
ça lui suffit que quelqu'un arrive juste
à ce moment là on voyait pas censé
savoir à quel moment les voleurs sont
arrivés vente seulement très vigilante
pour que c'est ancré dans moi depuis
toujours il y a deux ans elle a été
l'une des premières animatrice du réseau
voisin vigilant
depuis tout le quartier s'y est mis
cette voisine par exemple qui note en
son absence tout mouvement suspect je
prends les plaques d'une circulation
et puis où j'ai informé la police
municipale elle verrait une camionnette
qui s'introduit chez moi et qui déménage
des choses sales trouverais ça suspect
et vice versa voyez donc dire c'est que
nous ne sommes pas là automatiquement
personnes à venir à la maison
80% des habitants de mouans sartoux
montana oeil sur leurs portes et sur la
maison du voisin
madame ruth gisi à les référentes c'est
quelque chose survient elle appelle la
police puis active la chaîne des voisins
et parfois cela débouche sur une
interpellation
c'est arrivé à cette dame blonde
escroqués par un vendeur de brioches
j'ai vite compris et j'ai dit vais très
bien monsieur moi j'appelle la police
municipale il n'y a aucune délation chez
nous la frontière elle s'arrête là où
commence le travail justement des
officiels de la police et la gendarmerie
ils font des choses que nous ne pouvons
pas faire mais entre les forces de
l'ordre et les voisins vigilants les
échanges d'informations fonctionne si
bien qu'on peut s'interroger
ces indicateurs bénévoles ne serait-il
pas tenté de pousser le cynisme plus
loin ce monsieur par exemple regrette de
ne pas avoir pu empêcher le cambriolage
du voisin est intervenu
on me dit pas intervenus ça plus tard ça
dépend qui si c'est sont des jeunes on
m'a dit de ne pas forcer non c'est pas
recommandée dix ans on essaie de bien
sensibiliser justement nos voisins et de
bien les cadrer avec les moyens qu'on a
mourier antenne sélection dès le départ
de mouans sartoux à nice 46 communes des
alpes-maritimes ont rejoint le réseau
voisin vigilant
un oeil d'azur braquée sur la sécurité
la politique on l'attendait sur
l'agriculture nicolas sarkozy a
finalement décidé de consacrer son
déplacement dans la drôme tout à l'heure
au débat controversé sur l'identité
nationale un débat nécessaire et noble
dit-il nicolas sarkozy qui au passage a
pris les devants dans un autre débat
celui sur la burqa
alexandre kara jean-marc nouknouk une
marseillaise un peu inattendu pour
rendre hommage aux martyrs du vercors
inattendus comme ce déplacement
officiellement consacré à l'agriculture
et finalement dédié à l'identité
nationale en quelque sorte un ajustement
très politique
objectif pour nicolas sarkozy justifier
un débat très contesté depuis son
lancement par eric besson
nous devons parler de notre identité
nationale
ce n'est pas dangereux c'est nécessaire
l'objectif est simple ne pas laisser le
thème de l'identité nationale à
l'extrêmement nos enfants la france est
un pays où il n'y a pas de place pour la
burqa où il n'y a pas de place pour
l'asservissement de la femme
vous êtes un discours aux accents de
campagne à quatre mois des régionales le
chef de l'état cherche ostensiblement à
mobiliser son électorat traditionnel
on ne peut pas vouloir bénéficier de la
sécurité sociale sans jamais se demander
ce que l'on peut faire pour son pays
on ne peut pas vouloir bénéficier des
allocations chômage sans se sentir
moralement obligé de tout faire pour
retrouver du travail
l'identité nationale un débat qui
concerne chaque citoyen une bonne raison
pour le chef de l'état pour en faire une
priorité présidentielle et ironie du
sort le discours ne s'est pas terminée
par la marseillaise apparemment
quelqu'un avait oublié d'apporter la
bonde sont une image de françois fillon
en visite pour trois jours au vietnam
visite axée notamment sur l'économie un
premier accord de principe pour la
livraison de quatre airbus a été signé
il est question aussi de la vente de
nucléaire civil
le lancement par le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel d'une campagne pour
alerter les parents sur l'impact de la
télévision sur les jeunes enfants
vous le savez des chaînes ont récemment
été créé pour les moins de 3 ans doit-on
interdire la télévision au tout petit ou
en limiter l'accès un livre relance
également les interrogations
jean françois feer et diane richard les
pingouins rigolo offre chaque soir un
peu de répit à la famille maillard à
barthélémy avant tout trois ans
seulement et déjà captivé par l'écran à
maman aussi qu'ils apprécient le calme
dans la maison mais vingt minutes pas
plus
il n'y a pas qu'un enfant forcément à
suivre
ça me ça me donne moi une marge de
manoeuvre pour pouvoir m'occuper de
manière individuelle d'autres enfants
dans un temps limité chez l'effort tout
se passe différemment
la télévision est systématiquement
éteinte quand la petite valentine 16
mois et dans la pièce malgré toutes ces
précautions
difficile d'échapper à l'envahisseur
chez la nounou notamment elle même a des
enfants qui avaient regardé la
télévision comme tous les enfants un peu
plus vieux on va dire et c'est sûr que
le soir ça peut arriver car la
télévision avec eux de plus en plus la
télé s'adresse aux tout petits et
fascine programmes dits pédagogiques
dessins animés aux couleurs vives et
même chaîne qui leur sont réservées à
leurs avions france en 2007 elle avait
fait polémique
on les accusait d'être abrutissante à
l'époque l'un des directeurs se
défendent et nous apportons aujourd'hui
c'est un environnement protégé
conçu spécifiquement pour les tout
petits avec un contenu éducatif
deux ans après l'audience de ces chaînes
émises de l'étranger restent
confidentiels
le conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
n'a pas pu les interdire mais les
déconseille fortement même s'ils
savaient calme c'est pas beau pour leur
développement parce qu'ils sont trop
habitués à recevoir comme ça des stimuli
nerveux trop puissant et qui sont pas
capables de gérer
il vaut mieux et un athénée qui regarde
maman passe l'aspirateur pendant trois
jours dès le 20 novembre les chaînes
apposeront ce logo sur leur programme
afin d'alerter les parents du danger car
oui selon la majorité des
pédopsychiatres il ne fait aucun doute
la télévision est néfaste aux très
jeunes téléspectateurs un enfant avant
trois ans il construit sa personnalité
et il a besoin pour ça de pouvoir
interagir avec tous ses sens toucher
porter à la bouche flairé un enfant
devant la télévision
il regarde il entend y bouge plus il
faut donc parler décrivent telle image
avec son enfant en moyenne à 4 ans ils
passent plus de deux heures par jour
devant la télévision sans là pour vous
aider à protéger
actualité à l'étranger avec la
sécheresse qui s'étend dans l'hémisphère
sud
on a parlé ici même de l'afrique et via
l'amérique du sud était également touché
images ici de bolivie où elle sévit
depuis plusieurs semaines elle a déjà
causé la perte d'au moins onze mille
têtes de bétail
et puis en australie c'est la canicule
qui fait rage avec des températures qui
dépassent les 35 degrés pour le
cinquième jour consécutif et images ici
d'adélaïde chacun tente de se rafraîchir
comme ils peuvent vous ne voyez même les
colas et déjà les pompiers font face à
des normes incendie alors un pays est en
pointe pour les recherches agricoles en
région désertique
il s'agit d'israël et voici une
expérience étonnante des oliviers
irriguée à l'eau saumâtre dans le désert
du negev reportage martine
laroche-joubert mossi harmon le désert
du negev à 2h de jérusalem le royaume
des bédouins à laboratoire pour israël
voici l'unique oliveraie au monde
irriguée à l'eau saumâtre une oasis de
300 hectares loin de leur mode de vie
ancestral
les bédouins apprennent à maîtriser la
technique de la cueillette des olives
différente chaque année
dernière il y avait beaucoup de livres
mais cette fois ci il y en a moins à
l'origine de ce miracle un forage
pétrolier une déception pas d'or noir
mais une découverte une immense nappe
d'eau salée à 700 mètres de profondeur
en vrai magicien ouri yogev la
métamorphose en or vert la plupart des
fruits ne pousse pas ici des oliviers
c'est possible mais dans ce désert de
pierres pas de prodige d'un coup de
baguette magique ou rio gars c'est un
expert il connaît les secrets de
l'alchimie de ses oliviers leurs ennemis
le puits nous utilisons ces bandes de
politique pour éviter les effets de la
salinisation comme zéréhoué olivier avec
de l'eau salée l'eau s'évapore mosphere
et le sel se concentrent sous la surface
grâce au plastique quand ils veulent la
pluie ne pénètre pas le sous sol et
n'entraîne pas le seul à l'intérieur des
rations des livres commercialisés par
cet homme d'affaires le sel enrichi les
sols en minéraux et apporte beaucoup
plus d'antioxydants à l'olive elle-même
et donc tous les éléments volatils qu'on
peut retrouver dans l'huile d'olive sont
supérieurs à la normale une réussite
pour une expérience particulièrement
précieuse ici nous sommes en israël il y
à peu de terre et peu d'eau ou bien nous
profitons maximum des conditions telles
qu'elles sont ou bien on ne fait rien
d'autre pays aride l'inde l'afrique
s'intéresse à cette science des oliviers
une parcelle encore mais les bouches
d'une planète plus riche et plus verte à
la fois il est 20 heures et 19 minutes
rester avec nous à suivre l'invention
américaine qui pourrait changer la vie
de centaines de milliers de personnes
handicapées elle permet de commander un
ordinateur ou un fauteuil roulant avec
la langue l'économie avec la
traditionnelle étude sur les dépenses de
noël cette année encore notre budget
moyen pour la table et les cadeaux
devrait reculer montant 650 euros par
foyer
et puis faut-il croire aux effets des
cosmétiques bio et peut-on être sûr des
produits qu'on achète
le secteur pèse maintenant 2% du marché
il est en pleine croissance
d'abord donc les sciences avec ce
procédé mis au point par des ingénieurs
d'atlanta aux états unis et qui offre de
nouvelles possibilités en particulier
aux personnes à mobilité réduite
c'est un système de guidage par la
langue envoyés spéciaux loïc de la
mornais crise ericsson cruz bogle est
tétraplégique
il n'a plus l'usagé ni de ses mains ni
de ses bras ni de ses jambes et est
complètement dépendant d'autres
personnes pourtant le voici qui
manoeuvrent son fauteuil roulant selon
sa propre volonté et avec précision
regardez ça bouge c'est presque
imperceptible il utilise son cinquième
membre
la langue c'est le laboratoire de
l'université d'atlanta qui vient de
créer cette invention spectaculaire
l'espoir d'une indépendance pour de
nombreux paralysé dans le corps humain
l'influx nerveux pour commander les bras
et les jambes passe par la moelle
épinière
il est tétraplégique on la moelle
épinière sectionnée cerise ils peuvent
bouger la langue comme vous et moi
karl avantages de la langue c'est
qu'elle est contrôlée par un air relié
directement au cerveau et probe la
découverte c'est cette pastille
infiniment plus petit qu'une pièce de
monnaie fixé sur le bout de la langue
un ordinateur calcule les mouvements de
la langue vers les dents à chaque temps
correspond une fonction particulière
certaines pour allumer la lumière ou
naviguer sur internet d'autres pour
diriger son fauteuil
par exemple si je veux tourner à gauche
je dirige la pastille sur ma langue
verma dans gauche là en bas comme ça
lattès si je veux tourner à droite
canine droite en bas et mais incisif duo
c'est pour aller tout droit
l'apprentissage est facile nous avons
testé ce dispositif
il suffit de s'entraîner au moyen d'un
programme spécial de jeux vidéo la
langue fonctionne comme une souris
d'ordinateur c'est elle qui contrôlent
ce petit plongeurs orange
comme vous le voyez il ne m'a fallu que
cinq minutes pour maîtriser les
fonctions de base de ce système avec un
léger cheveu sur la langue il est vrai
ce système est déjà tellement au point
qu'il devrait être commercialisé dans
les deux ans à venir pour un prix
d'environ 7000 euros
mais à tokyo les japonais imaginent
plus fort encore cette machine lee les
impulsions électriques du cerveau il
suffit de penser à gauche pour que le
fauteuil tourner à gauche
mais cette technologie est bien plus
compliqué est actuellement nettement
moins au point que le contrôle par la
langue l'économie sachez d'abord que
michel rocard et alain juppé se sont mis
d'accord la commission sur le grand
emprunt pop rose proposera un montant de
35 milliards d'euros
le rapport sera remis dans une semaine à
nicolas sarkozy les voilà qui nous amène
à l'étude annuelle sur les dépenses de
noël budget moyen prévu cette année 650
euros par foyer
un budget qui baisse encore pour la
deuxième année consécutive de 3 5%
caroline thébaux dominique bonnet les
liste au père noël s'allonge avec tout
ce que petits et grands ont commandé
cette année ça risque de lui coûter très
très cher une caméra un portable
ce n'est pas venu une ferrari les
présences est en effet le premier budget
pour les fêtes
selon le cabinet deloitte les français
comptent dépenser environ 420 euros pour
les cadeaux 165 pour les repas 65 pour
les loisirs et sorties des vacances
total 650 euros par famille
un budget en baisse de 3,5 pour cent par
rapport à l'année dernière
pour beaucoup les cordons de la bourse
reste serré mais pour les enfants la
voie est libre
je n'achète que des jeux vraiment ciblé
ce que mes enfants n'ont pas eu l'année
précédente
c'est ok nos moyens quoi mais bon on a
quand même fait une exception pour nos
petits et les adultes débutants les
oubliera pas mais ça sera la fin sachez
que le petit billet au pied du sapin
c'est ce qui ferait le plus plaisir aux
adultes avec vêtements et cartes cadeaux
pour les courses cette année encore il y
a ceux qui piétinent et ceux qui servent
42% des français interrogés comptent
aller sur internet
c'est devenu le deuxième lieu d'achat
après les hypermarchés
car l'objectif est toujours le même
faire plaisir à toute la famille au
meilleur prix la voc du bio s'étend aux
cosmétiques le secteur est en pleine
croissance même les grandes marques s'y
met car contrairement aux aliments
biologiques les cosmétiques naturels ne
sont pas plus chers que les autres
alors faut-il croire à leurs effets
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé laurence de cher frédéric faure
dans quelques semaines elles vont
envahir l'hexagone ces affiches d'une
campagne de publicité annonce le
lancement d'une nouvelle gamme de
maquillage bio par un géant français de
la beauté marques naturelles dont les
formules sont naturels de 98 à 100% la
cosmétique bio un marché émergent qui
tente l'industrie 30% en plus chaque
année c'est 500 produits nouveaux en
rayon crèmes gels douche et maquillage
on trouve aujourd'hui tout au naturel
c'est un marché émergent
on y croit on espère pouvoir prendre une
belle place sur ce marché
et pour cause comme en agriculture
biologique la cosmétique bio attire le
client comme ce couple qui n'achètent
plus de produits classiques
j'ai envie de gagner à tous les coups
que ces produits dérivés de l'industrie
chimique qu on nous met dans le dans ces
produits qui peuvent donner d'abord
parce que les allergies des comme ça
quand on est allergique on ne peut pas
les utiliser
et puis ensuite je sais pas pour vous
mais pas facile de décoder les
étiquettes des produits bio fobio les
fabricants soeur sur les mots les noms
des laboratoires mais en regardant de
plus près la composition des produits
pas beaucoup d'ingrédients naturels
alors comment s'y retrouver dans les
enseignes spécialisées
tout est labellisé mais voilà les labels
il y en a plein l'important c'est quel
que soit le produit c'est de rechercher
sur l'emballage sur le flacon le label
donc c'est le signe de la certification
ici on voit le label cosmébio qui le
label français en france aussi la belle
nature et progrès pour les produits de
marque allemande on a le label bdih avec
ces labels sont exclus les composants
issus de la pétrochimie parabènes
suspectés d'être cancérigènes éthers de
glycol parfums aux colorants de synthèse
silicone et paraffine un cosmétique ne
peut jamais être bio à 100% car dans sa
composition il y a beaucoup d'eau et des
minéraux qui peuvent être naturel mais
pas certifiable seuls les éléments
d'origine végétale peuvent être
cultivées en agriculture biologique pas
plus efficace qu'un produit classique le
cosmétique bio est il meilleur pour la
santé c'est mieux d'utiliser un
cosmétique bio en ce sens qui aura moins
de produits chimiques à l'intérieur mais
il faut pointer du doigt le fait que les
cosmétiques bio peuvent entraîner des
intolérances des eczémas de contact des
allergies donc bio ne veut pas dire
totalement inoffensif certifié ce qui
peut être biologique
c'est le rôle d'ecocert un organisme
indépendant
aujourd'hui c'est jour de contrôle chez
ce fabricant de cosmétiques bio
j'avais le numéro de lot afin de le
retrouver sur
les matières premières contre les des
factures l'éplucher pour éviter les
fraudes et quelquefois même des produits
finis des magasins sont analysés en
produisant quatre fois plus qu'il ya
quatre ans ce fabricant cherche toujours
de nouvelles formules les cosmétiques
bio ont évolué laissant place à des
parfums plus agréable qu'il y a dix ans
et une conservation plus longue
on n'utilise pas par exemple de pots de
crème ou ici ce que des flacons airless
dans lesquels n'y a pas d'air donc aucun
risque d'oxydation une garantir une
bonne conservation d'ici cinq ans un
produit sur 20 sera certifié bio pas
plus chers que les marques de luxe
le bio en cosmétique un bel avenir
devant lui on reste dans le domaine de
la santé et on revient maintenant comme
prévu sur l'une des informations
principales de ce début de soirée on l'a
appris juste avant le début de ce
journal un cas probable de syndrome
guillain barré est signalée par le
ministère de la santé un cas enregistrés
après vaccination contre la grippe a
ce syndrome est une maladie rare du
système nerveux il est observé à cet
important sous une forme modérée en
l'occurrence précise le ministère
bonsoir jean daniel flaysakier vous êtes
notre spécialiste santé en direct de
tours
ce syndrome c'est l'un des scénarios
redouté par ceux qui rejettent ce vaccin
oui c'est un phénomène extrêmement rare
après vaccination on estime le risque
après vaccination à un cas sur un
million mais il faut dire que le
syndrome de guillain barré y en a à peu
près 1500 1800 par an en france et qui
sont généralement causés à près d
infection non pas des vaccinations et
des inflexions
c'est après notamment des grippes ou
encore des gastro entérites et comme
vous le rappeliez ce sont des atteintes
neurologiques ce sont les cellules de
défense de l'organisme qui vont attaquer
les plénières du patient ou le pardon
entraînant des troubles poumon plus ou
moins gras poêlé jusqu'à la paralysie
mais dont 80 90 % des cas ces syndromes
régressent spontanément sans séquelles
il ya quelques formes graves mais elles
sont rares dans l'état actuel des choses
il est très difficile d'imputer ce
syndrome de guillain barré à la
vaccination pourra savoir quand est-ce
que sont apparus les troubles
neurologiques par rapport au moment où
la personne a été vaccinée savoir si
elle n'avait pas un état infectieux
avant d'avoir été vacciné
en tous les cas il faudra donc déjà des
mais ces choses là et puis savoir que
cet accident est rarissime
je répète dans les cas de vaccination on
estime la fréquence à 1 pour 1 million
et en termes de protection le vaccin les
avantages du vaccin reste énormément
supérieurs à ses risques même si cette
affaire risque de jeter effectivement
une ombre sur la vaccination
jean daniel flaysakier merci pour ces
premières explications comprend jean
daniel qu'il faudra attendre d'avoir
d'autres informations pour être
réellement fixé d'une part effectivement
pour savoir si ce cas est imputable à la
vaccination et d'autre part sur la
gravité qui ne semble pas importante de
ce qu'est en cours en tout cas le
ministère de la santé rappelle qu'il
s'est engagé à la transparence sur les
effets secondaires de ce vaccin d'où ce
communiqué en début de soirée deux
images de sport maintenant avec d'abord
ces rencontres franco française
aujourd'hui au tournoi de tennis de
paris bercy tsonga s'est qualifié pour
les quarts de finale il a dominé en deux
sets un gilles simon diminué par une
blessure au genou autres qualifiés gaël
monfils en deux sets également aux
dépens de julien benneteau tombeur hier
de rodger federer qui n'aura donc pas
été plus loin avec ce poids magnifique
vous le voyez 2
gaël monfils et puis sachez qu arnaud
clément est éliminée face au serbe
djokovic
on l'a appris il ya une heure henri
sérandour et moore ancien membre du
comité international olympique il a été
pendant 16 ans président du comité
national olympique et sportif français
henri sérandour avait notamment été à
l'origine de la candidature malheureuse
de paris aux jeux olympiques de 2012
il est mort des suites d'une longue
maladie henri sérandour avait 72 ans
avant de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle l'un des principaux titres le
coup d'envoi dans toute la france de la
vaccination contre la grippe a comme
prévu elle n'a pas vraiment fait recette
on ne s'est pas bousculé dans les
centres malgré l'exemple très médiatisé
ici de roselyne bachelot
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
isabelle martinez d'un peu de soleil
entre les gouttes à 20h35 envoyé spécial
avec guilaine chenu et françoise joly
demain 13h élise lucet à 20 heures et
tout le week-end laurent delahousse très
bonne soirée
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr
que nous faisons